hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the senate voting to acquit former
president trump of inciting the capitol
hill insurrection
but days later the naacp and mississippi
representative bennie thompson
the democratic chairman of the house
homeland security committee
are suing mr trump and his personal
lawyer rudy giuliani
alleging they conspired to ignite
violence gop congresswoman nancy mace of
south carolina weighs in
on president trump's acquittal his
future and her push for schools to
return to in-person learning
the electricity grid struggles in texas
continue with record high demand
amid historically cold temperatures fox
news contributor and assistant editor of
the wall street journal's editorial page
james freeman and fox news radio's jeff
monasso discussed the blackouts
and how the issue is putting the future
of energy generation in the spotlight
plus commentary from former utah
congressman and fox news contributor
jason chaffetz
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm sandra smith i'm brett baer i'm
ainsly earhart and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday february 17 2021
i'm dave anthony it's more than a month
since the riot the trump trial is over
and one house republican tells us
there's no sign of unity i've been
threatened to be shot by republicans now
and democrats
right we're seeing this rhetoric ratchet
up it's not getting better right now and
we need to really
look at ourselves and say what are we
going to do
about this in the future we've got to
have some common ground
alisa brady an icy blast of winter
leaves millions in the cold heating up
the debate about green energy
when there is a a push to move to
renewables instead of the
more reliable sources such as coal you
do
unfortunately have to sacrifice some
level of reliability and i'm jason
chaffetz
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
just days after former president trump
was acquitted
at the senate impeachment trial it is
not over for at least
one house democrat congressman benny
thompson
and the naacp are suing the former
president
and attorney rudy giuliani who led many
trump election challenges
accusing them of conspiring with the
far-right groups the proud boys and the
oath keepers
in the deadly capital attack in
violation
of the 150 year old ku klux klan act
which attempted to stop political
violence right after the civil war
trump spokesman jason miller says the
former president
did not incite or conspire with anyone
what does president biden think he
certainly supports
the rights of individuals members of
congress and otherwise to
take steps through the judicial process
press secretary jensaki also says the
president would support a 9 11 type
commission
to investigate the attack democratic
congresswoman catherine clark tells fox
you know this is a chance to take it out
of the realm of politics
and put it into the hands of experts
but republicans are turning their
attention more on the national guard
troops still deployed
and all the fencing at the capitol you
see the seven foot fencing and it's not
barbed wire
apparently it's razor wire and it looks
like
you're in a green zone of a war-torn
country congresswoman nancy mace
is one of the new house republicans from
south carolina and here we have a
congress that doesn't want to
fund a border wall or southern border
yet they want to fund
um fencing and keeping people out of our
capital and so i think one of the
frustrations we've seen this is putting
it lightly that people have with
congress and with our nation's capital
is the hypocrisy
and the way that we apply different
policies or
ideologies to our country people should
this is a free country
we shouldn't be blocking people from
visiting our capital it is a safe place
today
and we want people to admire and respect
the freedoms
that um we cherish i mean obviously was
well over 40 days ago when the capital
was attacked you don't think there's a
threat any longer you
you think the troops should go away i do
believe that
uh the troops can go away i would like
to see an
investigation on on or at least have
some hearings or
some more information on why they're
going to be there for so long there was
talks of them being here through
march now i'm hearing i'm reading news
reports of through the fall
but if there are threats on our capital
or members of congress then
we should be aware of those issues as
as they come up too but but right now i
mean you can hardly get around the
capitol
um i do feel safe at the capitol that
day obviously on january 6 was an
abhorrent um it was a day of violence
where five people died
and the only thing standing between us
and the violent writers and the
insurrectionists were the capitol hill
police
and so we all need to make sure that we
are safe when we go to go to work but
but right now um i don't think that when
you look around at the capitol and the
fencing you have for miles and miles and
the
and the troops it looks like more of a
green zone right of a war-torn country
and it's just something i've never
thought i'd ever see in my lifetime
and there's no effort to to show the
free country that we are i mean that is
reflected
in our capital the house speaker nancy
pelosi has said that she's going to set
up a 911 style commission
into what happened on january 6. do you
think that's a good idea
well i mean the thing that we have to be
cognizant of is that
um you know when we look at how this may
or may not be done when these kinds of
commissions have been done in the past
we want to make sure there isn't
any open-ended entitlements coming out
of it or that we shred
any of our bill of rights like the
fourth amendment after the the 9 11
commission i think that's really
important
i do want to get to the bottom of what
happened but we just had an impeachment
where no witnesses were called
in an impeachment that was
unconstitutional um
but when we look at what happened it
would be great to get to the bottom of
it to understand
um how it happened and what what
measures were taken to secure the
capital
what was requested or what was done and
not done
so that in the event that this happens
in the future we don't have a repeat of
it
um i think one of the reasons you know
obviously this was such a violent
day for everybody but we witnessed it
across the country we've never seen
anything like it
we want to make sure that we never see
anything like it
again that occurs but it's not just
january 6 we should be talking about
there's been violence across the country
for the last
year and i've been talking about this
since the event that was a very strong
voice after january 6
on the republican side of the aisle but
we've got to take responsibility for
ourselves and we've had
rhetoric on both sides of the aisle i've
been threatened to be shot by
republicans now and democrats
right we're seeing this rhetoric ratchet
up it's not getting better right now and
we need to really
look at ourselves and say what are we
going to do
about this in the future we've got to
have some common ground
um that can exist and we can and find a
way to acknowledge the problem that we
have in this country with the
divisiveness
maybe take a break from social media
from time to time and and sort of
cool our heels a little bit but what's
happening right now
is wrong and it's very concerning for me
as a mom i'm a single mom of two kids
that i'm raising and this is not the
country that
i was raised in that we were raised in
and this is not the future
this divided future that i want for my
children
and i'm going to be a strong voice
calling it out on both sides of the
aisle
of course the senate did vote that the
trial was constitutional some
republicans sided with democrats on that
and it went forward and president trump
was
ultimately acquitted because they didn't
get the 67 votes to convict
but the minority leader of the senate
mitch mcconnell as you watched i'm sure
said that the president was practically
and morally responsible for inciting
what happened
do you agree with him on that i do
believe that that rhetoric can lead
to violence and i look at that what
happened to me in the days and weeks
leading up to january 6
that i had folks that were threatening
to shoot me on social media
and this isn't this isn't okay we do
have a responsibility i believe a moral
responsibility
um to to ensure that that doesn't happen
again that we don't
instigate any kind of an attack but one
of the things that i think is missing in
this conversation that is that
you know they didn't get two-thirds of
it i do believe uh impeachment was
unconstitutional spoken about it
previously because in the house
when they filed articles of impeachment
there was literally one hour of debate
on the floor with democrats and one hour
of debate allotted for republicans
there was no investigation open there
was no commit there were no committee
hearings there were no witnesses called
nothing in judiciary or even a special
committee before the articles of
impeachment were passed out of the house
and sent to the senate
if you can take away due process for the
president of the united states you can
take away due process for any
american the one thing i do want to add
is that if pr if
prosecutors believe the president
incited the attack then
they can bring charges in criminal court
um
and anyone that that was acted in a
violent manner
um at the riots at the capitol dome
should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law and that's the same for anybody in
any city
across the country who's tried to bring
harm to people or their property
late tuesday afternoon former president
trump put out a statement
very critical of the top republican in
the senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell
calling him a dour sullen and unsmiling
political hack
writing mcconnell will never do what the
former president says must be done to
secure a fair
and just electoral system in the future
and looking ahead
the former president wrote where
necessary and appropriate he will back
primary rivals who espouse making
america great again
and the policy of america first now in a
new quinnipiac poll this week
three-fourths of republicans in the
survey say they want trump to have a
prominent role in the party's future
what does congresswoman mace think of
that
when you look at the policies of his
administration over the last four years
whether that is fewer taxes we had lower
taxes and i know that in my district
when we had the tax cuts and jobs act
come through
wages went up when you when you allow
the market to thrive
supply and demand can dictate wages you
don't need a government dictating a 15
minimum wage when a good market
a good economy will the wages will be
that and even better than that
we saw under his administration
operation warp speed where we had
vaccinations approved rather than in 10
years in 10 months
and now we are seeing the benefit of
that as we roll out the different
vaccinations of course we would all like
it to be a much faster than it is right
now
but we wouldn't be where we are today
had we not had these gains
in my own district we are against
offshore drilling off south carolina's
coast
for example and president trump signed
the moratorium a 10-year ban
on drilling off our coast and so we had
a tremendous success under his
administration and those policies
showed we had the lowest unemployment
rate for everybody in this country
we had great gains economically and
those are the things that we should be
championing in our future because we're
seeing
now that we've lost the house we've lost
the senate we lost the white house we're
going to be seeing policies
are that come through that will not be
bipartisan um that'll be
driven by the leftist agenda and they
will be detrimental to our economy so
the things that
that he achieved under his presidency
under his administration those are the
things that
those are the things that we should be
working toward and
and trying to do better there is still
this move
toward a 1.9 trillion dollar corona
financial aid package out of the house
keeps working on it
the senate will have its version as well
what are you i i know you're sort of on
the outside looking in as republicans
because democrats are putting this
together
what are you hoping happens
i was hoping previous to our committee
hearings in the house last week and i'm
on i sit on three committees now
i was hoping all the talk of unity was
going to be true that we could work
together
but come to find out last week not a
single and the committee that i was on
that a single republican
amendment was passed through that was
the directive my understanding
that we wouldn't be able to pass any
amendment to the budget reconciliation
process well that's not working together
having a one-way street is not unity
i haven't lost hope i am hopeful i
received some pledges from some of the
my colleagues across the aisle to work
with me on certain issues that i'm
passionate about
and um i'm going to hold them to that we
cannot sit here
and talk about unity and then have a
one-way conversation where we
we don't have a a meeting of the minds
and don't have republicans and democrats
working together that's not how unity
works
and so i'm going to be hopeful for the
spring but
time will tell whether or not we can
actually pull this off there is money
that could be allocated for schools
where do you think we should be on i
know some school systems are hybrid some
are full-time
others are still shut down what are you
trying to get
what do you think should happen as we
get into the square well on that note uh
congress has appropriated 68 billion
dollars to
expedite the reopening of schools but
only 4 billion of that has been spent
we've got the cdc we've got dr fauci
we've got the science telling us when
precautions are in place
at school it is a very safe and healthy
learning environment for our children
because they're
six feet apart they're washing their
hands they're wearing their masks
and so what we have in this country this
policy when we're not following the
science
has been very detrimental to moms in the
workplace who can't go to work because
they're at home with their children and
children who are
suffering mental health is up 31 er
visits and mental health
with high school students right now we
have children who are failing we have
children not showing up for virtual
school we have kids who can't get school
get lunches that they're going to be
malnourished we have kids who don't have
access to the internet
this is enormously detrimental and it
shouldn't be teachers unions because
it's teachers unions that are driving
the debate and driving the decisions of
the biden administration it should be
parents
who are making the decisions for their
kids whether or not they want to be at
home 100 of the time or whether or not
they want to be in a hybrid situation
or whether or not they believe their
kids should be in school five days a
week
i have a district in in my congressional
district
where the rate of incidence of students
with covet 19 and these are kids going
to school five days a week is one half
of one percent
and so it's very safe for them
and we're doing a huge disservice by not
listening
to parents and the students that have
enormous needs right now
congresswoman nancy mace republican from
south carolina thanks again for joining
us
thank you
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary
coming up yet another round of ice and
snow is
on the march across the u.s but it would
be hard-pressed to match the size and
scope
of the last one which dumped more than a
foot of snow on parts of the midwest
spawned a deadly tornado in north
carolina and brought icy conditions to
parts of the south that rarely
have to deal with it a storm system now
blamed for more than a dozen deaths in
several states
as arctic temperatures also descended
from canada
all the way to mexico it's just
critically critically important
for the power to be restored as quickly
as possible houston mayor sylvester
turner especially concerned about
seniors as millions of texans wait for
power to be restored
after a combination of frozen equipment
and surging demand
prompting rolling outages the senior
vice president of centerpoint energy
kenneth coleman
pledging to restore power as quickly as
possible but on tuesday afternoon
only able to offer a trade-off we still
have to have
the same amount of power outages but
we're trying to trade off those who've
been out for the extended
period of time and replace them with
customers who haven't been out
temperatures aren't expected to get
above freezing in texas until friday
and even if people have somewhere else
to go it's too icy in some areas to risk
getting there we're seeing the hundreds
of roadways that are
really not safe to travel statewide
they're telling people stay home
jeff monasso is the midwest
correspondent for fox news radio
down in houston 1.3 million people
without power state wide about 4 million
and we've heard from emergency officials
down in houston saying
don't heat your house with grills don't
heat your house with
anything gas related or or your
generators keep them away from your home
they've they've done almost 100
calls the fire department in and around
houston over carbon monoxide related
poisoning and that was
after two deaths a woman and her
daughter tried to stay warm in their car
they started the vehicle
the garage door was shut and and so they
lost their lives and so but people are
are panicking and i think that one of
the things about the northeast
and in the northwest in in the midwest
is we're all generally
winter weather hearty uh we know how to
deal with this we've been there
done that and we have the infrastructure
but uh down in texas the deep south
when there's this much snow when there's
this much ice and there's these freezing
temperatures they don't have the
resources
and you add to that the fact that the
power grid has failed
and that's causing some huge problems so
what are the local officials
in texas telling people they should do
to try to cope with it because obviously
when you don't have power and
temperatures are dropping into the
single digits
um you know your options get to be few
and far between
uh in terms of bundling up enough to not
um
get injured especially if you're elderly
yeah i mean
what they're doing now is they're
telling people to get to warming centers
uh in
in the sad part about that is that um at
least down in houston they're already
maxed out
uh they're over capacity on those so
they're telling people uh
contact your your your neighbors
elder elderly people your family members
your friends can they take on more
people in their homes that do have power
get somewhere warm but by all means do
not
stay in your house if your house is
freezing i've got friends in dallas and
family uh in in
austin and they're telling me that their
the toilet bowls are now ice
iced up it's that cold inside their
homes so it's it's to the point where
it's it's a little dangerous
uh or it's a lot dangerous and and so
uh while resources are stretched thin
do what you have to do to get somewhere
warm and you know it's not as if
some of these places have never had snow
or ice before it happens you know
occasionally but i guess it's just not
frequent enough to lead to any sort of
you know annual budgets or annual
preparation for those things like other
parts of the country that
get snow regularly would do but there
could be
as we always hear with climate change
you know more
frequent extreme weather in general so
are
officials in states like texas and other
parts of the south
starting to think about preparing for
these things to happen more often
or is it too soon he's trying to get
through this one right now i mean look i
think it's all of the above
uh we know texas governor greg abbott's
calling for an investigation
into the folks who run the power grid
there so
that's through the legislature perhaps
they will come up with an idea or a plan
because we have seen more of these
more frequent cycles of colder weather
uh in in the southern states so
you know maybe but to put it in
perspective if you look at the city of
detroit which got about a foot of snow
overnight still digging out
transportation uh and nightmares
happening there chicago and other places
but the city of detroit has about
2 000 miles of just city block city
streets
within the city limits uh that that
they're plowing out right now and they
expect to get that done within about 24
hours
if all goes right they've got the
infrastructure they've got the salt
they've got the plows
they've got the extra plows they go on
the garbage trucks and things like that
and so that's the infrastructure that
some of these southern cities and states
would need to be able to accomplish
goals like that and
it's so expensive to pull off and i i
just don't know that they've got the
resources for that
one other thing because i've heard
reports of windmills freezing over
natural gas pipelines frozen in texas
are did those things actually happen uh
yeah
we're seeing wind turbines if you go
into some parts of texas
all you see is wind turbines they're
everywhere
and a lot of them got gunked up with
with snow and ice and so they're frozen
solid and so what do you do i'm sure
there's going to be an argument about
renewables and
and contingency plans but the reality is
is
that system failed in the state of texas
so i'm sure there will be discussions in
in the future about that in addition to
the texas governor's call for possible
reform of the power grid operator
federal regulators say they will review
outages in both texas and the midwest
to identify and address problems in the
bulk power system
from the extreme cold weather i think it
is
a reminder to people how essential it is
that the power be reliable
james freeman is assistant editor for
the wall street journal editorial page
and a fox news contributor
and there has been such a focus in
recent years on
trying to move electricity systems to
renewable
sources like wind and solar i think with
an
environmental mission but perhaps
regulators often forgetting how
important reliability is and you see the
images of
wind turbines frozen amid these
temperatures obviously the low
temperatures are challenging
all kinds of electricity systems all
kinds of power production but
the fact is that we've seen it over and
over again it's
it's in texas and and we frequently see
it in california when there is a
a push to move to renewables
instead of the more reliable sources
such as coal
you do unfortunately have to sacrifice
some level of reliability and is it a
combination
of you know supply versus demand
um of course because when the weather
gets cold or
in the summertime when it gets too hot
if you have a you know big jump in
demand you have to be able to
to meet that with the supply but also
you know we hear about outdated
infrastructure or in this case
maybe just infrastructure that isn't
isn't ready
to make the transition that some
advocates are wanting to make to this
you know
renewable energy um there's one rice
university professor who basically
blamed an outdated power grid
in a tweet um but is so
is this entire issue then a setback for
the green energy movement
well i think we have to acknowledge that
if there is a
problem of lack of investment or
misdirected investment
the fault uh has to be put on regulators
these are highly regulated industries
obviously
more so in california than in texas but
utilities everywhere
are highly regulated that includes their
investments
i think what we are seeing is you you've
also had
big investment by federal taxpayers a
huge incentives to build wind assets to
build
solar and we see they are simply not as
reliable as other forms of energy even
if the heavy subsidies have now
made it appear that they're often cost
competitive with
more traditional sources of energy so um
i would hope one thing that would come
out of this
is a an understanding that
that the power needs to be reliable most
of all
and with the california wildfires and
the rolling
blackouts that have become basically a
new kind of normal there
um some of that is aimed at trying to
prevent
sparking fires because of aging
equipment but in the case of texas and
the extreme cold
these outages are blamed on a
combination of equipment freezing
um but also some intentional you know
controlled
outages to help manage supply do you
think
does it seem like this has caught not
only customers
but also the officials involved off
guard
yeah certainly there's been a massive
surge in demand and so
in order to to save their systems they
there have been uh controlled blackouts
and and
granted this is not normal to have
so freezing temperatures everywhere in
the state of texas
but i think uh reasonable people have
warned
that these events can and and do happen
albeit rarely
and that you want the most of all to
have a
a system that's there when it's most
needed um but i think it should be a
wake-up call for uh for
politicians for regulators for voters to
say what
what is our priority and obviously in
washington there's a lot of talk about
the biden plan to and discussion about
how quickly uh
he intends to move america toward a net
zero emission
energy system i think this is
a a moment to say what are the costs of
that kind of transition
obviously they are large financially but
they also
can have a a huge cost in terms of uh
people being able to
get power when they need it what do you
think will be the
immediate effect of this is it going to
tap the brakes so to speak on some of
these plans
or are we heading for congressional
hearings on these issues perhaps or
what do you think is could be you know
the most immediate result
i think the the main result is that it
now
changes the debate in washington which
is
for good reason has is largely about
costs uh
and this was an issue on the campaign
sort of how far toward that
green new deal is is our president going
to go
uh is it going to be a 2 trillion dollar
commitment
is it going to be more than that but i
think what this
issue does is it reminds people that
there are issues beyond money here and
i think there will probably be new
pressure
uh on team biden as it rolls out its
climate agenda to to make the case
that the sacrifices asked of people
are justified by the science
james freeman assistant editor of the
wall street journal editorial page
and a fox news contributor thank you so
much for your time
you too thanks lisa
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
jason chaffetz
what's on your mind live it about what
she called the
failure at the top in the wake of the
january 6th breach
of the united states capital house
speaker nancy pelosi insisted that the
sergeant-at-arms for the house of
representatives be fired
he subsequently resigned and pelosi
appointed an
interim sergeant-at-arms the senate made
a similar move
pelosi also moved to fire the chief of
the capitol police
at a press conference on january 7th
pelosi said
there was a failure at the top of the
capitol police and i think mr steven's
son
he hasn't even called us who is
ultimately
at the top of the capitol police pelosi
knows
she is she and the senate leader though
they don't manage day-to-day operations
have ultimate authority over capital
security
they failed she quickly vowed to fire
the sergeant-at-arms and the chief of
capitol police
but what about her own responsibilities
and culpability
and what all agree was an inadequate
response
in intelligence failure and shameful
preparation
for such an event pelosi's long-term
approach to security has apparently
failed to protect herself the united
states capital
members of congress and the public if
we're serious about holding the people
at the top accountable pelosi should
also have to answer questions
about her own leadership here are some
questions
pelosi should answer well it was your
role in authorizing or denying national
guard support
before and after january 6th after the
2011 shooting of now
former representative gabby giffords
what changed with regard to security
after the shooting of republican house
whip steve scalise
were any changes made to security what
happens when a member of congress's life
is threatened
how are they expected to protect
themselves
in 2018 25 000
was allocated to each member's
reimbursement
allowance mra for security did that work
do you have enough cameras in the public
spaces inside and outside the capitol
why can't law enforcement secure doors
in the capitol and why isn't there
bulletproof glass
why were known coved infected members
allowed on the grounds
of the capitol you insisted members
should be fined five thousand dollars if
they failed to pass through metal
detectors
should you be fined for not passing
through the metal detector
you said the enemy is within what did
you mean
and who specifically are you afraid of
in congress
how do you respond to the february first
letter from former
capital police chief sun your own home
was vandalized this year on january 1st
yet nobody was arrested the san
francisco police department was quoted
saying
unidentified suspects had painted
graffiti on the garage
door and left a pig's head on the
sidewalk
how does this happen to the speaker of
the house
speaker pelosi you need to answer these
questions
i'm jason chaffetz a fox news
contributor and former chairman
of the house oversight and government
reform committee
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news
listen and download the fox news hourly
update on your time
the trending stories you need anytime
you want it listen and download now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes